une église devenue musée puis
transformée pour la deuxième fois en
mosquée c'est l'histoire de la basilique
sainte sophie à istanbul une
métamorphose qui divise les communautés
turques
construite au ive siècle cette basilique
chrétienne est d'abord transformé en
mosquée en 1453 lors de la chute de
constantinople
elle devient 500 années plus tard un
musée et perd son statut de lieu de
culte une place des plus touristiques
dans le pays
en 2018 pas moins de deux millions huit
cent mille visiteurs s'y étaient rendus
faisant de ce lieu le deuxième musée le
plus visité de turquie sous l'impulsion
du président turc recep tayyip erdogan
la tendance évolue le président souhaite
à nouveau convertir la basilique en
mosquée une volonté controversé mais qui
parvient à prendre forme le 10 juillet
dernier
comme dans toutes mosquées les portes de
sainte-sophie resteront toujours
ouvertes à tous turcs et étrangers
musulmans et non musulmans
face à ce changement de cap la
communauté internationale réagit des
manifestations sont organisées par des
chrétiens en israël la france la grèce
et les états unis avaient déjà mis en
garde
ankara sur ce sujet en russie certains
politiques par le même de provocation si
cela se produit ce sera une provocation
en revanche si les autorités turques que
l'ess sainte-sophie sous son statut
actuel ce serait une marque de respect à
la culture mondiale en respectant le
christianisme et l'orthodoxie et ce sera
sans aucun doute un signe de respect
pour notre pays qui agit entre autres
comme le principal partenaire commercial
de la turquie
de son côté l'unesco appelle au dialogue
mais regrettent déjà la décision prise
par l'exécutif turc sainte sophie est
une composante des zones historiques
d'istanbul inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
son statut de musée reflète
l'universalité de son héritage est en
fait un puissant symbole de dialogue
première basilique de l'histoire
chrétienne construite sous l'empiré
romain sainte sophie à multiplier les
statuts et n'a cessé de faire parler
d'elle